Under a bright sun,...
...skiers and snowboarders are enjoying the kind of powder you might find in the Alps,...
...but this isn't Europe.
This is Lesotho in southern Africa.
My name is Ramokotjo Hope.
I'm a snowboarding and a skiing instructor, and this is my playground.
Though a vacation in Africa might typically conjure images of palm-fringed beaches...
...or herds of wildebeests migrating across the savannah,...
...the continent also has five mountain ranges with enough seasonal snow...
...to create the potential for slopes.
One resort can be found in Lesotho,...
...the enclaved kingdom tucked into South Africa's Drakensberg mountain range.
Hope says most people don't think of Africa for a ski holiday,...
...but are amazed at what they find.
This isn't much, but people come in and have a whole lot of fun.